This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. Therapy is a great tool for facing your fears and finding ways to overcome them. Because sometimes the scariest thing is not facing our fears in the first place. That's right. And therapy is a great tool for facing your fears. And you know fear can be such a stumbling block in your life and we are all fearful. And what a better thing to do than to talk it out with someone. If you're thinking of starting therapy you could give
BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online. It is designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Here's how it works. You fill out a questionnaire. You will get matched with a licensed therapist, and you can switch therapists at any time for no additional charge. So if this feels like something that you might want to give a try, you can overcome your fears with BetterHelp. Visit BetterHelp.com slash office ladies today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelp, H-E- e l p dot com slash office ladies.
I'm Dave and saving with TD insurance made me feel like I scored my own jingle. Save on home and auto like only you can at td insurance.com slash ways to save TD. Ready for you. Hi everyone. We recorded today's episode a few weeks ago, but before we play it for you today, we wanted to pop on because Jenna,
you shared something very personal on your Instagram and you said you'd also like to share it here on Office Ladies. Yes. And this is our second try at this because I got so emotional the first time we started talking about it. It's just really hard when someone you care about is going through so much. But I told Angela that if she starts crying, then I'll start crying.
Yeah. I know, Jenna, you have so much you want to say. Yeah. So I'm aware that this is a big share, and it's kind of hard to know where to start. But since I'm one of those people who tends to deal with emotional subjects by leaning into facts and statistics, we all know that an Excel spreadsheet is my happy place. It really is. I will start there. Last December, I was diagnosed with stage one triple positive
breast cancer and for anyone who doesn't know what that means I did not have a clue. Triple positive breast cancer is a very aggressive form of breast cancer that can spread and grow quite quickly but luckily my cancer was caught very early. It had not spread into my lymph nodes or anywhere else in my body. However, it still required the greatest hits of cancer treatments, surgery, chemotherapy, radiation. All of which has been going on this past year.
And lady, I know someday you're gonna share more about this in your time when you're ready, but I just have to tell everyone as your BFF, I can't believe how much you held onto these past few months. Well, I have to say, I've had a lot of people helping me hold onto this. I know. I did not carry this alone. I know you didn't, but you just had such courage and such grace. And you know, I'll cry if we talk about it too much, but I want you to share the first
steps after you were diagnosed. Yes. So the first thing was I had surgery in January. Then I did 12 rounds of chemotherapy. I had to do it every week. I completed that in May. And then I completed three weeks of radiation in July. And I like sharing those details, Angela, because those were things when I was diagnosed, when I was reading about other people's stories, I appreciated those details. So that's why I'm offering them now. I also want to say that I was recently
rescreened. I can very happily say that I am cancer-free. Cancer-free. Yes. I remember the day you told me that you were cancer free. I remember how emotional we were in that moment. It was tears, and we were so thankful to hear those words. How does it feel for you to finally share this? Well, it all still feels very surreal. Even as I'm saying this out loud,
even after making this announcement, even after living through it, I can't believe it's true. I mean, it's just, it's one of those things that you just never think is going to happen to you. Yeah. I mean, for a long time after the diagnosis came down, Lee and I just kept thinking that this was some mistake on the paperwork. Yeah.
I remember just saying to you, like, are they sure? Yeah. And, you know, I am still receiving treatments. There are things that are designed to keep me cancer free. So I get an infusion every three weeks of a drug that's called Herceptin. I'm also taking a drug each day to block my body from absorbing estrogen.
So I'm still riding waves of super fun random side effects. But I am over the hump of the big treatments and I'm feeling more hearty and I really wanted to share my story in case it can help other women. Really that's what it's about for me. Yeah. We talked a lot about how you wanted to go through your treatment with privacy and how important it was. All I could think about during this time, Jenna, was that I just wanted to protect you,
you know, and I wanted you to be able to focus all of your energy on your treatment and healing. And I knew that when you were ready that there would be a time for sharing. And I also know that you sharing is going to help so many people. And now you're ready to share. Yeah, I mean, I did need that bubble. Yeah. I did need to focus all my energy on my treatment and my family. I have kids. You have young kids and this was really that time where you just needed the space to heal. Yes.
And to put your health first, do you want to tell everyone how you found out? Yeah. I also want to say, Angela, you are a great protector. I lost my hair during chemotherapy, and I was wearing these hats with fake hair coming out the back to all of our podcast recordings, all of our meetings. You guys, Angela started wearing hats to all our meetings too.
We became the Hat Gals, and it was really moving to me, Angela. This was your idea. Angela also came over to my house, and she stayed with my kids during my surgery so that they didn't have to go to school that day. And it just meant so much to me that they were with you. Well... I could go on and on about all the ways have to go to school that day. And it just meant so much to me that they were with you. Well.
I could go on and on about all the ways that Angela and Josh supported us during this time. But to answer your question about how I found out, it was through my routine mammogram. And by the way, that test was inconclusive, because I have really dense breast tissue. So my doctor ordered a follow-up ultrasound, and that is when they found the tumor.
It was in my left breast. It was too small to feel on a physical exam. So I don't know exactly how my sharing can be of service, but maybe this is your reminder out there to schedule your mammogram, because it was that routine appointment that caught my cancer early enough that it had not spread, and it was more easily treatable. It's so important. It's something you and I have talked about a lot,
that, you know, it's easy to put those things off and to put yourself second. You take care of everyone else, you put yourself second. And I remember after you were diagnosed that you, you know, I was just amazed by you, Jenna, because you just did that thing that you always do, which is you immediately wanted to get as much information as possible? Yeah, I mean, I was scared. And the thing that made me feel better was that information gathering. I really scoured the internet looking for any information I could find about my diagnosis. I read interviews and cancer blogs and Reddit threads. I got connected with an amazing team of doctors and nurses.
They have been so patient and explained things over and over again until I understand them. Their patience is amazing. And then I got connected to other women who had had breast cancer and they helped me and I really want to pay that forward. So this is just the start. I hope to share more about my journey in the future. But right now, lady, we have a re-watch to finish. We do because I love doing our podcast. I love it so much and I want to say thank you to you and to Sam and Cassie. I just think that the space that we have here to work in,
I am so lucky to have. And I know I'm lucky. Going through cancer treatment requires a lot of flexibility. This job afforded me a lot of flexibility. And more than that, though, it gave me a safe place to come and laugh and escape. I felt a sense of purpose here. It is important to me and I cannot thank you all enough. And this is a thank you to our Office Ladies community as well for this space existing, I guess.
And I like being in it. And we have a really good episode today. I want everyone to hear it and enjoy it. Well, lady, we love you. And we are here for you. And I'm gonna give you a hug, but I bet there's lots of other folks just sending you virtual hugs as you share.
And you're right, we have a great episode and you're so good in it. So let's hear it. Here it is everyone, AARM part one. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends.
And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Hello. Hi.
We have a big, big episode today. I mean, the next four are big. That's right. It's AARM Part 1, Season 9, Episode 24, written by Brent Forrester and directed by Dave Rogers. And here is your summary. The group readies themselves for the premiere of the documentary.
Wow, it's really happening. It's happening. Dwight is going to conduct a series of challenges because he needs an assistant to his assistant. That's the AARM, Assistant to the Assistant Regional Manager. And Jim's having a great time, but Pam wonders if Jim staying in Scranton for her is a mistake. Meanwhile, Dwight reveals his plan to propose to Esther, Darryl tries to Irish exit from
Dunder Mifflin, Andy lines up to audition for a TV singing competition, and Angela and Oscar bring Philip to work and sort of co-parent him. Yeah. A lot is happening. They're actually a really good team. They really are. Well before we dive in I'll have you know I am using a mug today that is maybe my new, not maybe, it is my new favorite mug of all time. It's the cutest thing. I've never seen anything like it. Tell us about it Jenna. Alright we went through our fan mail and this was in there. It is a handmade mug by this gal named Katie, C-A-T-I-E, and it is a
mug with pockets. It looks like denim. Mm-hmm. With the stitching and there's all these little denim pockets. And you know I love to drink my coffee out of a handmade piece. I know. It just brings me joy in the mornings. We should also say that Katie made me a mug as well and it has hummingbirds on it. Yes. Does she get us or what? She definitely gets us. Katie wrote us the sweetest letter, Angela. She said that she is from my hometown of St. Louis, born and raised, although she does not say fardy far. Not like Phyllis.
No. Okay. She currently lives outside of St. Louis, but pottery is her passion. And Katie, I can see why. You are so good at it, Katie. We love these mugs. So incredibly talented.
And I want to give her a shout out, but Katie, unless I'm missing something, I do not see an email address. I do not see her last name. I do not see an Instagram handle. We are looking for you. We are looking for you. So Katie, if you hear this,
or anyone that knows Katie in St. Louis that made us coffee mugs with amazing hummingbirds and pockets, will you tell Katie we love them and we'd love to give her a proper shout out? Well, I know that I have not had a big soap box in a while. Do you have one? I might have one. Is it about the Jim and Pam storyline?
It is. Is it going to be fast fact one? It's not. I'm saving it for later, but I'm prepping because I feel like this is my mug for soap boxes now. You got your pockets mug. I do. My FastFag 1 is that AARM Part 1 aired on May 9th, 2013.
And remember how we said that Diversity Day was like the pilot after the pilot? Well, this was considered the finale before the finale. This was really the last time we're going to see all of these characters in this chronological real time, because the finale is going to flash forward in time. That's right. Well, this episode was also very well received by critics and fans.
Jenna Mullins of E! Online said that it was, quote, full of emotional moments that seemed like love letters to fans who have watched the show since the pilot, which is really what Greg was going for in these, especially, last few episodes. But do you remember how it was Greg's intention to bring back different cast members throughout the last season?
How we've seen Roy, Jan, all of Dwight's crazy friends. Todd Packer. Mm-hmm. Well, he also wanted to make sure that we had an episode that featured that classic Jim Dwight dynamic. That is what inspired this episode. You know, Jim's been gone.
We haven't had this playful Jim Dwight business. Yeah. And so that is what inspired this episode. Well, I love Dwight and Jim, you know, so it made me very happy to see them in their shenanigans again. And now, fast fact number two, Angela, I'm handing it over to you.
Thank you. So I'm going to do fast fact two and three today. Here's fast fact number two. A few things. This episode is the start of the final DVD in the whole box set. We're on the last DVD. It's disc number five, season nine. Here are the bonus features on it. There are season nine bloopers, the final table read of the whole series. Yeah, that'll tug on the heartstrings. The 2003 casting auditions of the cast and an auto-tune version of Andy's audition song from this episode. I have a few really fun things from my digital clutter that I will be
sprinkling into AARM part one and two. Here's the first one. Per my emails that I clearly never get rid of, guess what we were doing this week? What were we doing? I'll give you a hint. What? It's also on the call sheets. We were filming the interviews for the office a look Back. Yes, of course. You know, when I rewatched this episode, I immediately flashed to us sitting in Caffeine Corner doing those interviews between scenes. In fact, I specifically remember
walking out of the warehouse set where we're doing the whole obstacle course and doing those interviews. Well, you know, John organized the filming of this. It's actually all on disc four, but they're so great. They really capture where we all were in our minds and in our hearts as we were filming this episode. And I thought we should play some.
Oh, I love this. You know, they really got a combination of cast, writers, crew, talking about their time on the office. And then it aired on NBC before the finale. That's right. All right, so now for fast fact number three, and I'm going to share clips from A Look Back every week until we finish the rewatch. And for this episode, my first clip is us all sort of pondering, what is this show?
Oh, I like it. It was simple. It was just an office. Very little happened at Dunder Mifflin. They didn't really get much work done. It is a quintessential American workplace comedy show. It was awkward, painfully awkward and hilarious. We've all had a boss. They get in the way of you doing your job. I just love how real it was.
We were everybody's experience at work. It celebrated those human interactions that annoy us all and make us chuckle or make us mad. I think that's what allows people to connect to the show, because they can see themselves, they can see their jobs, they can see their relationships in this show. The premise of the show when we started was, what if you had the world's worst boss? And the irony was this is a guy who bought a mug for himself that said world's best boss.
And then later in the clip, I really thought BJ sums up the show really well. Let's hear it. Who could not relate to the show? The guy wants the girl but can't have her. There's a weirdo working next to you and your boss is insane. Yeah, that is it. Is that perfect?
That is perfect. All right. Well, I'll be sharing a few more things from my digital clutter throughout this episode and the next one, plus some more clips from that look back. Wow. I can't believe that we're really getting to the end, Angela.
I know, you know, I was trading emails with Brent Forrester who wrote this episode and he said, oh my gosh. He said, I am having feelings. Is this the last time I get to share about the office with you guys? And I said, nope, no Brent, it's not. Yes. Did you tell him about Office Lady 6.0? And I said, nope, no, Brent, it's not. Yes. Did you tell him about Office Ladies 6.0?
Yes, I did. I said, Brent, don't you worry, we're not going anywhere. No, Brent, we are still going to be emailing you constantly. We promise. And I know we shared about this at the top of our show last week, but for anyone who missed it, after we are done breaking down all of the office episodes,
we will be busting out office ladies 6.0. I love it I love the title. I love it so much. You guys know the reference when Katie the purse girl comes into the office during hot girl Michael calls her Pam 6.0. Jenna and I were talking about this we think it's because there was an iPhone 5 at the time or like a Microsoft something there was something 5 at the time. Or like a Microsoft something, 5? There was something 5. Something 5.
At the time. But it just tickles us so much that we are now gonna be Office Ladies 6.0. And basically, we're gonna keep chatting about the office. We're gonna dig deeper into characters and storylines, webisodes, themes, we're gonna interview people, and of course, there will be plenty of best friend banter, deep dives, soap boxes, I'm sure.
What? More soap boxes? Possibly. And for all of you that love rewatching the show over and over and re-listening to our breakdown of the episodes, don't you worry, because we are going to rerun the entire rewatch in order every Monday from the beginning. And guess what we're calling that? Second drink. Second drink, isn't that perfect? Yeah, we're gonna pop on each week with some bonus tidbits.
You know, there are people who tell me that they just found the podcast. Yeah, and we've been breaking it down for five years, but people are discovering it and we wanna been breaking it down for five years, but people are discovering it and we want to make sure it's there for them. Well, I know, for example, in the UK, they just got the Office on Netflix. So for anybody who wants to re-listen or start listening, we'll be starting our second drink on November 11th.
And Office Ladies 6.0 starts on November 6th. All right. Why don't we go to break? But before we do, real quick, I have one more thing, you guys. You know I love some seasonal clothing. Uh-huh. Okay, so I saw some really cute Halloween socks that feature little cats, and I got us all a pair.
Aw, thanks, lady. This is what happens to me when I'm alone in a shopping mall. I'm like, oh, cat socks, I'll buy those. Well, I want to give you fair warning. I've been saving Instagram videos of Halloween crafts that you can make from Dollar Tree. So please tell me we can make one. OK.
We might be crafting one Saturday soon. You guys each get to pick out a pair. Sam, it said one size fits all. I don't know. But maybe they'll fit everybody. All right. Let's take a break and we will be back with AARM Part 1. We are back. We have cute Halloween cat socks and we are ready to break down this episode. Kevin is going to arrive to work. He waves at Aaron. There's a very sophisticated sort
of like keypad buzzer thing happening. He buzzes the keypad and Aaron says the tea in Nepal is very hot. And Kevin has written some kind of like passcode on his arm and he answers, but the coffee in Peru is much hotter. And then Aaron lets him in. Dwight has a talking head where he explains he has made some upgrades to the office security. He got these new doors from an old jewelry store. He has this passcode that he sends everybody first thing in the morning. It's not the KGB, but it's a start. He loves to lock it up. He loves a tight security system. And then he arrives to work and he gets the code wrong and then they hit the
steam button. Dwight says it's harmless steam to scare intruders, although he wanted dangerous steam, I guess, but it was too expensive. Creed likes it. He's, I think, been purposely steaming the room because it's saving him on dry cleaning. Now we have our opening credits. They're very short, but we got a lot of mail about them. I bet I can guess. Yeah.
We have a new manager. Where are our new credits? What little bobblehead thing would Dwight have pushed to the front? Angela, you are not the only person who is disappointed. Let me read this one from Jesse B. in San Clemente, California, who said, we have been waiting as long as Dwight has for him to be manager. So now that he is finally manager, why does he not get the ending manager slot in the intro? I know. Well, we reached out to Dave Rogers,
director of this episode. We asked him a bunch of questions, and this is the first one. Dave said that there was discussion about adding a Dwight as manager shot at the end of this title sequence, but ultimately they never filmed anything new for it and here is why. The main reason was they wanted to use Pam and Jim kissing as the final image in the main title for several episodes because they felt that at this point, the idea of who is manager had been eclipsed by the characters personal lives.
And they felt like the focus here of these final episodes was more about summing up Jim and Pam. He said also they were really pressed for time and they literally didn't have time to shoot a new little manager title with Dwight. And also there was so much in this episode that they had to make the main titles really short anyway. So there were kind of three reasons. I was thinking it was for time that we were just really crunching to get these episodes out and they were such big episodes as it was. There's a whole entire Nellie and Toby
storyline that is cut. I know. So they really needed to use every second and minute they had for this episode. I'm going to tell you something right now. I would have preferred to see Dwight at the end of these end credits rather than Jim and Pam. And this is going to relate to my soapbox later. But Jim and Pam are on my last nerve right now. Okay. So, stay tuned for the soapbox. Stay tuned. Next up, we are in Oscar's apartment.
And there is a very interesting sleeping arrangement going on here. It looks like Oscar's apartment has sort of a main bedroom, and on either side of the bedroom, there are two walk-in closets. This is very nice closet storage. Baby Philip is in a crib in one walk-in closet and on the other side of the bedroom, Angela is sleeping in the other side.
Yes. Lady, I love these Angela and Oscar roommate scenes so much and I want to take a moment to appreciate how amazing Oscar's loft looks. It was built entirely on our stage. Our art department and set dressing did such a fantastic job. Here is my digital clutter item number two. I call it a loft because that is what our art department called it.
At the time, I was remodeling my own house and redoing my kitchen, and I loved the kitchen they built for Oscar so much, I asked them if I could have some photos of it. And one of our set dressers, James, aka Jim McDermott, we love him, sent me all the photos of Oscar's entire loft. I still have them, I found them, and I'm going to share them in stories. This is a gorgeous, gorgeous loft. I'll tell you two things that I noticed, two background catches that really impressed me, and I felt like they were great details. Let's hear it.
At two minutes and six seconds, Oscar has a red landline rotary phone on his bedside table. You know he does. You know he's a landline guy. He's ready. He's ready. He is ready. And then at two minutes and 11 seconds he has a red canister set in his kitchen. Mm-hmm. He clearly loves a pop of red. He loves a pop of color. I love these details. Well, Philip is gonna cry and Oscar tells Angela he's crying for her. They're getting ready for work. It's kind of like that busy morning where you're getting kids out the door. Angela's laying out Philip's outfit and Oscar says saddle shoes with denim. I will literally call child services. So Oscar is like
helping Philip's look. And I just love doing all of these scenes. They felt so easy and organic for these two characters to be roommates. This is definitely one of my favorite Angela storylines ever. Yeah, me too. Is this pairing. Me too. Speaking of pairs, Esther has driven Dwight to work.
Yeah. And they kiss goodbye. We learned some big news now in a Dwight talking head. You know, he's sort of listing off all the things that are going well for him. Manager of Dunder Mifflin, check. Owner of a 1,600 acre beet farm, check. Engaged to an actual milkmaid.
Well, almost check, right? That's going to happen later in the day. He's going to propose to her with his grandmother's ring from her butt. Well, from a bullet from her butt. A bullet from her butt. Yeah. Yeah.
Next up, Andy is going to arrive to auditions for America's Next Acapella Sensation. He's checking in, and he seems nervous. Like, will I be allowed to audition? They're like no problem head to the back of the line he's like yes yes I mean he felt like he had to list off his resume so far he was like you might know me from a TV documentary that's premiering tonight I also killed it in local theater and I'm
fresh off a hot industrial flick yeah they're like we don't care buddy just go get in line. I asked Steve Burgess where did we shoot this giant audition line he said we shot at Pickwick in Burbank we shot outside and inside their convention center. Pickwick is like a bowling alley and ice skating rink. It was. They tore down everything except the ice skating rink. The LA Kings purchased the ice rink and all the rest of it the bowling alley all the rest of it the convention center alley, all the rest of it, the convention center has been torn down and they're putting up condos. You are kidding me.
I loved that bowling alley. Wait, I bowled there constantly all the time. That was my bowling alley. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, I didn't know that. It was kind of like an LA, I don't know. I feel like it was iconic.
Yeah. Pickwick. Pickwick. Yeah. We got a fan question from Adam W. in Webster, New York, who said, At 3 minutes 36 seconds when Andy is walking to the back of the line, exactly how many extras were in this scene? There are so many. I wondered the same thing. The line looks like it goes on forever. Steve Burges said 234.
That's a ton for us. That's a lot. We also got a fan question from Nikita C. in Sydney, Australia who asked, why did the documentary crew continue to follow Andy after he left the office? They didn't follow Michael or Robert California or anyone else. Hmm. Guess who had an answer for us? Dave Rogers. That's right. Dave said the in-universe answer to this question is simple.
If a person moved far away and was no longer tied to the company like Michael in Colorado or Robert, California in Europe, then the documentary crew no longer covered them. They just couldn't afford to send crews to follow these people. They did couldn't afford to send crews to follow
these people. They did send a crew to Tallahassee though. Because our Dunder Mifflin people went. Ah, like the Stanford branch. Yes, Tallahassee, enough of the employees, went. Correct. They were still affiliated with Dunder Mifflin. Got it. He said also the cameras still followed Michael, Pam, and Ryan when they formed Michael Scott Paper Company because they were still local. They were still intertwined with the Scranton branch. They were also in the same building. True.
But the camera also followed Andy when he went to Florida to get air in. You know? However, when Andy went sailing on his boat with his brother, the crew did not stay with him. So because he was only very recently fired to pursue his dream of being a singer, the documentary crew felt that a trip to Pittsburgh to see if he was going to make it was worth following. I buy that. I buy that. It sort of wraps up his story.
And remember, he did spend a whole episode following his dream, not following his dream, I buy that. It sort of wraps up his story. And remember, he did spend a whole episode following his dream, not following his dream, following his dream. I think there is some value in knowing could he be back at Dunder Mifflin next week. Right, right. So that was how we explained it internally, why the camera is still with Andy.
I buy it. I buy it. Well, Andy is to have a talking head where he says he burned all of his bridges at Dunder Mifflin and it's time to become the next American Idol by winning America's next acapella sensation on channel TBD. I love that it was TBD to be determined. He said this is basically a new take on American Idol and The Voice because this time all three judges are mean. We now have a really great scene between Jim and Dwight and Dwight's office. Jim is going to give
him a sales form to sign but first he has to put it in the inbox. He can't hand it to Dwight. No. He has to put it in the inbox then Dwight signs it then Dwight puts it in the outbox where then Jim can pick it up and then they shake but Jim does not let go of his hand. And then this goes into one of those classic great fakie talking heads where you think it's just Dwight but we reveal the sidekick and it's Jim sitting just behind him. Angela did you do a breakdown of Dwight's office decor? No, I didn't. I did a breakdown of his hierarchy mobile. Well, that is good.
I did a breakdown of it. Well, I know everything on the hierarchy mobile table. All right, well, when we get to that, I will give that over to you. Let's hear it. Here's what I spotted. Multiple old-timey photos on his desk, on his credenza, the hierarchy mobile, a photo of a jet. Yes, I saw that too.
I zoomed in. I got the details on that. It is the IKHA-NA. It is an unmanned aircraft that is designed for high altitude long endurance science flights. And it was actually used in a joint project of NASA and the US Forest Service and was flown in to monitor forest fires in the Western US.
Huh. Mm-hmm. That's very specific. Very specific that he loves that particular aircraft so much. He has a giant picture of it on his wall. I also spotted some binoculars, a boar's head, and an award of merit from March 2002 from the Greater Scranton Agrarians for Outstanding Service to the Farming Community. What was on his desk?
Old timey photos. No, okay, next week we're going to break down what's on his desk. His desk is very efficient. He doesn't have a bunch of crap on his desk like everybody else. That's fine. We're still going to break it down. He has the inbox and the outbox that you mentioned and some old timey photos and the end. That's it?
Yeah, it's not a lot. No magic eight ball. No magic eight ball, but there is a kind of what looks like a type of eight ball on his credenza. Listen. Not on his desk. I got you covered. You got the credenza?
Yes, because I zoomed in like crazy on that hierarchy mobile. So on the credenza, there is a gold frame with two old timey oval pictures of some old timey relatives. In front of it, at first I'm like, that's a magic eight ball. Yeah. No, it's not. What is it?
I zoomed in on it, it's a globe. Oh. Yeah, it's like. Of the earth? Yeah, it's like black, but then the continents are green. Oh, okay. And then I did a breakdown of the hierarchy mobile. Let's hear it.
Okay. I feel like this is the energy we bring to our mom detective stuff. You're like, did you do that? I'm like, no. I know. Did you do that? Ah, sort of.
Okay. Here we go. Now, if you want to go to 10 minutes, you get a really good view of this, okay? Oh yeah, they're gonna talk about it. They're gonna talk about it later, but we'll share what's on it now. It is a hierarchy mobile.
You have the center, and then you have two arms that go off of it, right? So down the center, you have Dwight K. Schroot, regional manager. Then you have Jim Halpert, assistant to the regional manager and salesman, Nellie Bertram, director of special projects, Angela Martin, head accountant, Oscar Martinez, accountant, Head Accountant, Oscar Martinez, Accountant,
Kevin Malone, Accountant. To the left of the arm you have under Dwight and Jim, Toby Flinderson, Human Resources, Pam Halpert, Office Administrator, Meredith Palmer, Supplier Relations, Pete Miller, Customer Service Rep, Aaron Hannon, Receptionist. And then to the right under Dwight and Jim, it has Darrell Philbin, head of shipping and distribution. Stanley Hudson, salesman. Phyllis Vance, salesman. Clark Green, junior salesman. Did we know Clark's last name? I don't think we did.
Now we do. He is Clark Green. And then Creed Bratton, quality assurance. Wow. Yeah, and I thought Phyllis might have been Phyllis Lapinvance, but she only has one last name listed. Oh, OK. There you go.
Clark Green, everybody. And I think we now have the official word on what Creed does as well. Quality Assurance. Yeah. Also, I didn't realize that Meredith was supplier relations. You know what?
Maybe we did know that, because isn't that why she was sleeping with people? Yes. Yes. Yes. We did know that. Keeping was supplier relations. You know what? Maybe we did know that because isn't that why she was sleeping with people? Yes, yes, yes. We didn't know that. That's right. OK. Well, before we leave this office, I've got one more fan question. It's from Alexis P and Marietto, Ohio, who said, there is a portrait of Dwight and Mo's in the background behind Jim inside
Dwight's office. Did Rain and Mike Schur have to sit for a portrait together? Also, who was the artist? Please tell us everything. Well, this painting has been established before. It was in the farm. That's right, Angela. Yes, I did not remember that.
But Dave Rogers pointed that out to me. Steve Burgess said that it was painted by Jules Kometsko, who Filchay had make pretty much all of our office art. She did Pam's watercolor, for example. She did this portrait. She did the one that you're gonna see in the conference room soon, and nobody had to sit for these portraits. She worked off of photographs.
Cassie, will you put her on our list for Office Lady 6.0? I'd love to hear about all the different artwork on the set of the office and what she created and just hear all about it. That's a good idea. Our list for Office Ladies 6.0 is really getting long. We realize there's a lot of stuff to still talk about. Yeah. Listen, I know it's a little early but I might need to take a break. I want to refill my pockets mug. I want to use the restroom.
I want to eat a cheese stick. Is that all right? I am never, ever going to stop you from eating cheese. All right. Ever. Thank you. Well, we're going to take a break and we'll be right back. We have had snacks.
And we're ready to talk about the fact that Jim and Dwight run a no-nonsense office. It's been six days since their last nonsense. That's right. Jim holds up a chalkboard that says five days, and Dwight erases it and writes in the number six. They're very serious about the no nonsense. Now Jim is going to join Pam at their desk clump, and he's going to say the pre-conference room
meeting went well, which bodes well for the post-conference room meeting. Ultimately, it all does depend on the conference room meeting itself. And then he gets a call, and it's from the folks at Athlead. They're wondering, you know, what's up with him? Is he coming back? What's going on?
Is he going to go on this three month tour? 32 cities or something like that? Yeah, they really want him to go. Jim is going to share a little bit more about this in a talking head. He said, I guess they would be meeting athletes on their own turf, building relationships. It sounds really fun. But he said no, and that's final because he doesn't want to risk losing Pam again over athlete. And then Pam has a talking head where she feels relieved, but also a little guilty. She kind of feels like he's giving up this big thing for her, but he seems happy. You know, he's been goofing around a lot and she really loves goofy Jim. Here's what I want to say to that. Oh, I've got my mug in my hand. Okay. Well,
my mug doesn't have pockets, but has a hummingbird that's ready to buzz around. All right, you start. Um, grow up. I spit off my coffee. Go on. That's what I want to say to Pam. Grow up. And Jim, you're adults. You have family. You have a home. Goofy Jim was in his twenties. They're older now and the two of them need to evolve as a couple at the workplace and with their goals and goofy Jim it just pissed me off. Okay. Okay. How was that? That was good and it was not my soapbox. Okay. So here's what I have to say. It's not that Jim almost lost Pam because he went to athlete. Jim almost lost Pam because he was dishonest and sneaky and non-communicative and made decisions without her input.
And now all they've done is swing too far in the opposite direction. What this couple needs is to communicate. And grow up. Yes, exactly. Jim is allowed to start a business, and Pam is allowed to feel overwhelmed and lonely. And there is a way that they could do this all if they would just talk to each other more. That's right.
It's not solved by just making this giant new decision to just come back and be goofy Jim. Clearly they are on my last nerve. Yeah. Equally, the two of them. The two of them. But also Pam is really on my last nerve. She's gonna get on my major last nerve
a little later in this episode. Okay. Right now it's both of them. All right. Nana put your tissue back in your pocket. I know. All right. All right. It felt good to get that off my chest. Well good. We are now going to have a conference room meeting and we learned Dwight begins every meeting with an inspirational quote. He's made himself a fast fact. Right now it probably seems fun,
but several meetings in he's gonna be like, God damn, I gotta come up with a stupid inspirational quote. He's gonna make Jim do it. Yeah, but then Jim will pass it on to his other assistant so he'll be doing it for himself. Here's the quote, some say the only failure there is, is the failure to try. And then he rings a buzzer, eh, that is wrong.
Failure of any kind is failure. Jim, over to you. Now Jim is gonna remind everyone of their no nonsense rule. Pam's gonna raise her hand and present a scenario to clarify whether or not this is nonsense or not. Now we have goofy Jim and Pam. Pam's example is if someone came in
and they were carrying water jugs, could you say nice jugs? I was very surprised by Pam's example. Pam's example sounds like something Todd Packer would pitch. Well, interestingly enough, this was a candy bag joke. This was not the originally scripted joke. Interesting.
Well, Jim says that's obviously nonsense. And what percentage of nonsense do we tolerate in this office? And everyone replies zero. No nonsense. You can't have any nonsense. Now Angela's gonna arrive. She's just gotten to work. She's a little late. And she's carrying Philip. Yes, we did film a whole scene that got cut out where Angela takes Philip to daycare and they turn her away because of the Senator scandal and Oscar. There is a blooper from that scene. It's on the DVD extras because the little boy playing Philip really wanted to like run. There was like grass and like stuff and I'm holding him and he wanted down and so I'm
like trying to say my line and juggle him and I just get so tickled. He wins. He gets down. I let him down. Well it's interesting you mentioned him because we got a fan question from Jesse in Edmonton who said, is the actor that plays Philip related to Rain in any way? Because they really look so alike and if not, hats off to the casting team. Well baby Philip was played by twins Vince and Evan Edwards, this was their first on-camera gig on a professional set. They were so cute and they were just so sweet. You know we've shared we would go and spend time with any kids that played our children just to get to know them and I just remember them being so stinkin' cute.
They were so cute. And they were also not related to anyone on the set. I asked Dave, what were the casting requirements to find this baby, Phillip? Uh-oh. Well, he said they did not actively search for babies that would look like Dwight or look like Angela. That was just luck.
He said their main search criteria was, could they do all the actions required? Because they actually have a lot that they need to do. And it's really challenging for babies to be on set with a lot of strange people, you know? And that after a meeting with several sets of twins, Evan and Vincent came in, and Dave said he instantly knew this was the new baby Shroot.
He said they were just really calm, very attentive, and they were really cool with being held by both you and Rain. Yeah, and Oscar. And you know, you'll see me in the conference room. I have a little toy that was his actual toy, you know. So we did have things even on set that were actually his to make him feel more at home. Well anyway that's how we found them and Dave did say he was absolutely delighted that they did sort of look a little bit like Rainn and
they had your blonde hair. He said it was amazing. It was really good casting. Dwight is gonna say Philip can stay and he announces that he's gonna let everyone off half an hour early so they can go watch the documentary. But you have to make up the time. You know, he said you can make it up by either staying 30 minutes later tomorrow or one minute for the rest of the month. Yeah, what would you do?
Would you stay 30 minutes or one extra minute? I would stay 30 minutes. I would stay 30 minutes and get it done. But also like, what am I gonna do with one extra minute a day? Unless I run one minute late usually. Then it doesn't change my day much. It doesn't.
Well, now we're going to see some talking heads from people. And we're getting some insights into how people feel about the fact that this documentary is going to be airing starting tonight. Meredith is like, I better come out smelling like a rose. I've been on my best behavior for nine years. If it wasn't for the cameras, I would have done some truly vulgar crap. Noted. Stanley notes that over the course of the documentary, he's had three affairs. And if you find his body in a ditch, let me save the police some trouble. My wife did it. Yeah. Kevin announces that he's going to be watching the
documentary at Poor Richards and that everyone is welcome. Well, why is he watching it at Poor Richards? Well, it has something to do with an all you can eat shrimp commercial. He charged the TV. Yeah. When the shrimp commercial came on, and he broke his TV. You know, my friend Luda, who I was out here with in my very earliest of days, she went to college with me.
We both came out to LA to be actresses. She was in a Red Lobster all you can eat shrimp commercial. No way. What was her part? She said she had a line. She had a line. That's huge. I know she had a line. That's huge. I know. She had a line. And then there was something about it where she got to eat
at Red Lobster for free for a while. We ate so much Red Lobster because she had done this commercial. I mean, it was so many of those cheddar biscuits that are so good. But I mean, she got us through that commercial and that free red lobster. It got us through some lean times in our early actor days. I bet. I did the Lay's Wow potato chip commercial and I had to eat them. You know, the one that had
a Lester that caused anal leakage. Yeah. I had to eat those chips all day. I take a bite and I'd say, wow, that was my only line. I was fine, did not mess up my constitution at all. Oh, so anyway, I didn't get free shrimp, but I did get some potato chips. You also didn't get anal leakage, which I think is good. It's a bonus. Yeah.
I think they discontinued those though, right? I think they did, and Red Lobster went out of business because of their all-you-can-eat shrimp. Oh my God, I think they discontinued those though, right? I think they did and Red Lobster went out of business because of their All You Can Eat Shrimp. Oh my god, I think that's right. Yeah. Right? I think I read that. I think I did too, that it really did them in. Well, it did Kevin's TV in. It sure did. See how it brought us back?
You brought it back, lady. Now, Oscar's also going to say he can't believe that this documentary is finally airing and notes that when they started filming he was still having sex with women. As was Kevin I believe. Creed says this airs tonight. Oh man if my parents see this I am toast. Creed's parents? I want to do an episode just called Creed.
Well who else wanted to do that? Was it Mike Schur or was it BJ Novak? One of the two of them told us that they wanted to follow Creed for a whole day. I'd love it. Well, now we're going to cut back to Andy. He's still waiting in line to audition. And suddenly a cute blonde is going to appear behind him. She wants some camera time.
She's Casey Dean. We don't need to tell you who she is. She's gonna tell you herself. Let's hear it. Woohoo! Casey Dean, Cincinnati, Ohio. Doctor, doctor, give me the news. I got a great Casey Dean for you.
No. America! No, this is my time. Casey Dean was played by Jessica Sinclair. She is a member of Upright Citizens Brigade Improv Comedy. She is a powerhouse. She co-created and starred in USA's Playing House. She has a podcast.
She sure does. Called The Deep Dive with June Diane Raphael, who, as you know, is one of the women who inspired us to start our podcast. We reached out to Jessica via our old producer at Earwolf, Cody Fisher, who produced their podcast, The Deep Dive. She put us in touch. We were so excited to hear from Jessica about how she got her role in The Office, and we had a few other questions for her.
We're going to sprinkle those in, but let's start with how she got her role in The Office. Hi, guys. So thank you so much for asking me to even weigh in on this episode. It really was a highlight for me. I'm a huge fan of The Office. And I know the show was ending, and I thought, well, that's it for me.
You guys were going to be the one that got away and at the last minute I got a call and I really think it was like two days before the before it shot so maybe Sandra Bullock wasn't available and then they went down the list but I was so happy to do it because Ed Helms is such a dear friend of mine and an old friend from the UCB, Upright Citizens Brigade Theater in our 20s, back when I had Hugh Grant's haircut from Four Weddings and a Funeral. And so I knew I was gonna get to spend the day with Ed,
so that was amazing. I love that she compared her haircut to Hugh Grant in Four Weddings and a Funeral. I have seen that movie so many times. I have an instant image of what her hair looked like. She's so funny. So funny. And she's going to give us some more delicious nuggets as we go on.
We now have a great scene with Angela and Oscar. They're over in accounting, but they're acting like an old married couple. Like she's saying, did you pack the snacks? And he's like, no, I told you to pack the snacks. And she says, well, whenever I pack the bag, you tell me I pack it wrong. And Kevin's like, guys, hey guys, guys. Yeah, Kevin's like, guys,
I want you to see this funny video on my computer. Look at my computer. Where someone says bold instead of cold. It's not that funny, Kevin. But then Kevin has an amazing talking head. It might be my favorite talking head of the entire series. Okay, well, you are not alone. Katie F from London, UK said, I have been waiting four years and ten years
because this aired 10 years ago. Got it. To tell you that Kevin's line in this episode is my favorite line of the entire series. I'm with you and I think we should hear it. Let's hear it. Philip, Philip, Philip. It's all about Philip.
I hate Philip. Here's what I want you to know about that talking head. It was not the one in the script. It was a candy bag alt. Oh my gosh. Yes. And I can share with you two other versions. Ready? Yes. So here's how it was scripted.
Philip, Philip, Philip. It's all about Philip. I hope Philip runs away. Oh, and this was another candy bag alt. And it really made me laugh. It's all about Philip. I hope Philip runs away. Oh. And this was another candy bag alt, and it really made me laugh. Kevin says, on the one hand, Philip is a cute baby. On the other hand, I hate his stupid face
and wish he'd go to baby hell. Kind of like that one. Anyway, Katie and London, I'm with you. Such a fantastic talking head. Well, this really points to that dynamic that you talked about originally, Angela, which is that you always felt like you were this dysfunctional family over in a county
where you and Oscar were the parents and Kevin was your kid. And now here you have your next kid and he's very jealous. We have a jealous toddler. You do. All right, Jim is gonna walk into Dwight's office and Dwight's like, not now, private time. I do have a background catch.
What is it? Eight minutes, 55 seconds. When the camera widens up, the mobile, the hierarchy mobile is moving. So I think this was like a second take or a retake cause it hadn't like gotten still. I think you're right. I think that's true. That's my background catch. I liked it. Well, Jim is going to say we've overlooked something. What?
Some PFN. That's right. Potential future nonsense. They're looking at the mobile. He says, look at it. We do not have an assistant to the assistant to the regional manager. We sure don't. Dave Rogers told me. Rain improvised a line here and it's so good. Which part? Is it about the hierarchy mobile? When Jim points to it, Rain came up with the line, I'd have to get some more wire and string, but it's doable. I liked that line. Very, very good. Good job, Rain. Very good job, Rain. Good job, Rain.
He's gonna MacGyver it. Meanwhile, Andy and Casey Dean are hitting it off. And host Mark McGrath is gonna come out and address the crowd. How charismatic was he? Oh my gosh. I so believed him as this character. We asked Dave how we got him for the show.
Dave said that they were hoping to get an Entertainment Tonight, like, extra type host. And Mark McGrath was perfect because he had been doing extra and also he is a musician himself. Yeah. You know, lead singer of the band Sugar Ray, everybody. That's right. Yeah. Dave said that when Mark McGrath said yes
to doing this part, he was so excited. Dave loves Sugar Ray. He said he has all their albums and he even had Mark's duet with Shania Twain, you know that song Party for Two, on a CD mix in his car. On the day we filmed it? No, no, just in general. Oh, because that would have been kind of wild if he pulled up and was listening to him at the same time.
Dave also shared with us that he was once at a rooftop movie premiere and saw Mark talking to some people, but he was too nervous to go up and tell him he was a huge fan. So now you fast forward to the morning that they're shooting these scenes together and Dave, I guess, went into hair and makeup. And when he entered the trailer,
he said, Where's the rock star? And he said Mark couldn't have been friendlier. He was really excited to play the part and he nailed the performance on the first take. Yeah. And Dave said, As a side note, Mark graciously invited him and a friend to be guests at his upcoming Sugar Ray show at the Greek Theater and Dave had a blast. Yes, Steve Burgess also talked about how amazing Mark was to work with. He confirmed that he nailed all his stuff on the first take and Jessica St. Claire also enjoyed working with Mark. Here's what she had to say. I also remember being very attracted to Mark McGrath and understanding why he had the career he did.
He's got Riz for days, but I did spend a majority of my time on set trying to catch the eye of Mr. McGrath. And sadly, we never had our moment where our eyes locked over craft service. But I'm not ruling it out, you know, but yeah, I think that's a woman of a certain age, like myself, can really get her motor running about Mark McGrath.
So that was a real highlight. Well, I'm a woman of a certain age, and I think all of us remember Mark McGrath. Yeah, he's got the Riz. He's got the Riz. For days. I went on his IMDB page, Ange, and I found this very funny trivia tidbit that I have to share.
Okay. It said that he is so often mistaken for Ethan Hawke that he sometimes just signs autographs as Ethan Hawke. And apparently the same thing happens to Ethan Hawke who signs autographs as Mark McGrath. That's so funny. Isn't that funny? Yeah. Well, I have one thing to point out from the script for this scene. You know when Mark mentions the mole and then he's like, oh, I wasn't supposed to say that. And then Andy's like, what mole? What are you talking about? I
already forgot about it. And Mark goes, good man right there. I'll see you guys inside. Good luck. All right. And then Andy's like, yeah, pour some sugar ray on me. And Casey Dean goes, wow, on a roll much? You totally made a connection there. And Andy's like, yeah, it felt good. It felt funny. I love this interaction so much. I went to the script to see if they had improvised any of it. I think they might have a little bit, but there was a scripted line I thought was really funny where Andy would have said, I should be resting my folks, but I can't stop riffing. Oh my gosh, the writers must have loved writing for Andy. Rest in my vokes. So good. So good. Now we're in the kitchen. Jim is pouring Pam a cup of coffee. He's very giddy. He's
having fun with this prank. We find out that he says by 2 p.m. Dwight is going to choose himself as the AARM, thereby making himself Jim's assistant. Now Darryl pulls up to the warehouse. He borrowed one of the warehouse trucks to deliver all his furniture to Philly. He has officially moved to Philly. He's all in. We find out that Darryl hates goodbyes, so he pulled an Irish exit and left before anyone noticed. No hard feelings, no feelings at all. Yes, please. And do not tell anyone he's there.
He doesn't want anyone to know. All right, now we're going to see what these challenges are to find the AARM. Challenge number one is know your superior. And I guess the way you know your superior is by predicting what they're thinking? Yes. Jim is like, what am I thinking? What song is in my head? No one can guess what Jim is thinking except Jim and Dwight say seahorse at the same time.
That's right. What are the odds of that? I mean, they're pretty good based on how this went down. Don't you think so? Yeah. Because what Jim did is just start to say a word as Dwight already said it. Let's do it, Jenna.
Ready? What am I thinking of right now? What? What? You're doing it. Stop it. Can I say something? What?
This is an acting exercise. Kristen Wiig and Fred Armisen on Saturday Night Live have a bit where they... They are the best at it. But they're singing. I know. As well. And then they're having to create a story, like new information. It is so good.
It's the best. It is. It's the best at this bit. It's so great. The whole bit is they have to sing a song on Weekend Update and it comes across like they haven't prepared and they're making it up on the spot. And they are. And visually they're having to watch each other to see what words they're saying.
We should put one of them in stories. It's so funny. We have to. All right. Challenge number two. We're in the conference room and we're going to talk about protocols. What do you do if there is a conference room meeting of very important people and a phone message comes in? Dwight hands this phone message to Clark who immediately reads it out loud and insults one of the people at the table.
Dwight is like, no, you don't read it. Clark has failed. Clark Green. Yes. Not gonna get a corndog. Does not get a corndog. Once again, Dwight is the only person who knows how to solve this problem properly. That's right. It's uncanny. I know. Uncanny. Mm-hmm. Jim has a lot of clipboard acting in this episode. A lot of pen clicking. A lot of pen clicking, writing stuff on a clipboard. Check mark making. Check marking. He's a clipboard guy. He really is. Well, back in line for America's Next Acapella Sensation,
Andy and Casey are really bonding over the fact that they're getting annoyed with other people that they think are gonna be pulling at the heartstrings of the judges. There's a army veteran, there's like a single mom, and they're sort of chatting about it Well when we were filming this episode, I guess a real-life drag race started to happen like on the street Oh, wow. Yeah, and everyone's like reacting to it. It's in the bloopers. I thought it was so wild I want you to hear it
Over by the porta potties. They were interviewing a homeless single mother with three kids. What? Who cares? Is that your ride? What is going on? What is happening? I think we can keep that one. What is happening? Is that a bank robbery?
What just happened? It was crazy. Oh my goodness. Did you hear how loud it was? Yes. Well, I asked Jessica about this and here's what she had to say. Now, apparently there was a drag race happening
during the scene when we were standing online. I don't have a memory of that, but I do remember that everyone on the line, all the background actors were so lovely and just a fun hang, you know? And that isn't always the case, but everyone was so excited to be there.
I think there was, you know, everyone was sort of a fan of the office and everyone was really bringing like a backstory to their characters. So that was really fun. Some of my favorite things to shoot are like situations like this, where you're in this like big line or big group of people for multiple scenes
because you really do kind of end up making up your own stories in the background and they become some of the most fun shoot days. Yeah, there's a guy with a cowboy hat in the background. Yes. I kept watching him. He clearly had a story for himself. I should point out that our guest star
who played the veteran was Nico Evers Swindle. He has been on Veep, American Horror Story, and Grim. He also played Prince William in the movie William and Kate. Wow. And everyone, Jessica is so amazing and funny. We're gonna have more audio clips to share with you next week.
And definitely check out her podcast with June Diane Raphael called The Deep Dive. And you also have to listen to her audio book with Casey Wilson. It is called The Art Dive. And you also have to listen to her audio book with Casey Wilson. It is called The Art of Small Talk. It's on Audible. It is so funny. The two of them are so hilarious.
They're gonna give you all the advice you need to go to any event with some great small talk. I feel like my trick of walking up to people laughing could be in this book. Okay. That's just a preview of some of their advice. I think that would qualify. They would like it.
Well, Andy is going to decide if the judges want a feel-good moment, he's going to give him a feel-good moment. He says, save my place in line, and he takes off. Yeah. What's Andy got up his sleeve? Oh, something good. Yeah. Once Andy got up his sleeve. Oh something good. Oh we're over at Caffeine Corner now and I'll be damned if they don't have donuts. Caffeine Corner! So many! They never had donuts! I remember being super excited to go over there and I did sneak one. They let
me have one. Well that's where we were doing all of our interviews for the look-back. Yeah. Mm-hmm. Darrell's gonna buy some to give some of the warehouse guys. He felt bad I guess because he didn't say goodbye to him. And Pam asked him how's it going at Athlead? Darrell couldn't be happier. He's so stoked. He's gonna like meet all of his sports heroes. He'll go to 32 different cities. He can't believe that Jim is happier at Dunder Mifflin. Yeah, he says he's not having any second thoughts about leaving athlete and Pam is like nope. I mean he seems happy. He seems happy. He's just gonna try to recreate
Office Olympics. Pretty much. Maybe a call for help. We're in the warehouse and there is a coffee obstacle course set up. Yeah you have two cups of hot coffee your boss needs his coffee. Here's the thing it's super piping hot. You got to step over three different sizes of like stacks of paper and then you go through this chair obstacle spinny thing. Yeah the chairs are upside down the wheels are spinning. This obstacle course was originally scripted to be outside, but Dave Rogers moved it into the warehouse. He said he moved it for two reasons. One, because he thought
it would be easier for Aaron to spot Daryl at the end if they were in the warehouse than if they were outside in the alley. But also he said whenever we did a lot of scenes outside we would all get hot and grouchy. And so he was like, let's move it inside folks. I saved myself. Exactly. Some grouchy folks. Phyllis is up first on the obstacle course and she's moving too slowly. Dwight can't take it. He like grabs the coffee from her, starts running through it, he's spilling coffee on himself,
it's like burning him, but you know what? He's going to get that coffee to his boss, which is himself. I would like to award myself a Razzie for my performance in this scene? Oh my God, I could barely watch it. Could I be telegraphing or showing or indicating anymore? Everyone, if you wanna be an actor, don't do what I'm doing in this scene. Stop it. I am serious, like everything about me, it's like, does anyone have eyes on me?
Like, how is Jim not noticing that I've turned into a complete sad sack and I'm just standing there like a big wet blanket? I mean, how about some subtlety, Jenna? When Jenna says a Razzie Award, she's talking about a thing called the Golden Raspberry Awards. It's a parody and it's an award show honoring the worst in cinematic failures.
Yes. They don't even cover television, but I think they should make an exception for me. It's a parody and it's an award show honoring the worst in cinematic failures. Yes. They don't even cover television, but I think they should make an exception for me. Stop it! I disagree. Ugh. Well, anyway, as if you couldn't tell, Pam is now very preoccupied with this idea that Daryl has planted in her head that maybe Jim is not actually as happy as he seems.
Yeah, Jim is going to present Dwight with a crown that he's made out of tinfoil and cardboard. Everyone applauds, but Pam, in fact, she runs outside. Very dramatically. Runs away. Overly dramatic, Pam. Dave said that Rain improvised a line at the end of this scene. Originally, it was going to end with Pam running out, but Rain improvised this line and I loved it so much. He says, from now on, anyone who needs to speak to me
has got to go through me first. That was so good. That was really funny. Rain knew his character so well. So well. Well, Jim is going to catch up to Pam outside. They're in that little alley by the warehouse and she she's worried Jim's like, Are you okay? And she says today was fun. But what about a year from now? What about five years from now? You know, she's worried that she's not enough for him and that he's going to resent her. I need to pick up my mug. Okay, here it comes pockets mug. All right, this is when Pam lost me. Uh oh. Okay. I'm gonna eat my granola bar, go. For most of the season, Jim has been on my sh** list, but all of this is
very crazy making to me on Pam's part. Hold up, are you calling bullsh** on Pam? Are you playing a bullsh** card? I don't know if it's a full bullsh** card because this is in character for them. This is just where their relationship is making me a little crazy. But herein lies the problem. In this scene, Jim says, This was my decision to come back, okay? I'm not going to resent you. This was my decision.
That's everything you need to you. This was my decision. That's everything you need to know. This is their problem. He decided to start the business and now he's decided to give up the business. Why are they not making decisions together and I am losing my mind? He bought a house. Yes. I remember hearing this amazing advice very early on about decision-making in marriage, and this is what I want to say to Jim and Pam. When you're at odds over something, but you reach a compromise, or you do eventually make a decision, that decision is not complete
until you both agree to take responsibility for the decision. So later on, if something goes wrong, you can't be like, see, I knew it, or like, well, that was you. You're the one who wanted it. Yeah, no, I told you so. None of that. Whatever the consequence is, we both made it. And if Jim and Pam had made the decision together
to start this business, and they took mutual responsibility for how that decision played out, we'd be in a very different situation right now. If Pam was unhappy with that decision, too bad, because you made that decision together. You're going to have to tough it out, Pam. That was a mutual decision. These are the consequences of your mutual decision.
But all that happens is Jim makes decisions. But Pam is like letting this happen, too. You know what I mean? Like, she just sort of like... Well, she's got to be more vocal. Yes. And he's got to stop making decisions without her. Jim is like letting this happen too, you know what I mean? Like she just sort of like... Well, she's got to be more vocal. Yes. And he's got to stop making decisions without her.
Yes. Thank you. Mug down. Thank you for hearing me. Well, Jim is going to have a talking head now. He's going to say, not enough. And then he looks at the documentary crew and he said, look, I need to ask a favor from you guys.
I know it's probably against the rules. And then we hear Dave Rogers voice say, okay, you got it, man. Very quick to say yes, I have to say. I know. I thought maybe they'd be like, um, let me think about it. Let me talk to some people. Or maybe just don't have them respond at all. I didn't think we needed the response. I didn't either. It sort of like threw me for a second. I love that Dave's voice got in the episode because I love him. But I also was like, well, that was quick. Well, you know, we've heard the documentarian's voice one other time and it was Dave at that time as well. Yes. You know, Dave said originally he just recorded his voice as like a temporary voice track. Yeah. And that the intention was that Greg Daniels would provide the voice of the documentarian. But Greg was like, no, I want it to be you. Meanwhile, Kevin is really acting
out over his lack of attention. He's throwing a tantrum. He says to Angela and Oscar, you know what? Tell Philip that a stupid little baby wish came true. But Angela and Oscar don't have time to deal with this. They're trying to get Philip down for a nap. They've created kind of a bed out of the bottom drawer of the file can, but they've pulled it out. They've put a bunch of blankets in. They've made a little, like a little bassinet. They have a little mattress thing on the bottom and some of his stuffed animals.
But Philip is too excited to nap. Yeah, Angela said he's very excited to be surrounded by all this paper and he even ate some of the paper, which Dwight overhears and is like, well, that's the best tasting paper. Hmm. Hmm. Meanwhile, in the break room, Phyllis, Erin and Meredith are confronting Darryl about the fact that he left without saying goodbye. Now Stanley's there too, but he's just kind of eating his lunch in the background. He's weighing in, but he's not as passionate about this problem. Oscar shows up there too. Oh, you're right. Yeah, clearly they
love Daryl and they wanted more time with him and they're really bummed he did the Irish exit. Daryl says, wow, they're definitely in a weird mood. I picked the wrong day to return a truck. I have a mug catch. Oh, let's hear it. Both Meredith and Creed are using their mugs from customer survey. Oh, that was season five. Yes. I just love the dedication to this mug thing. Me too. Well in Dwight's office him and Esther are now having a picnic and just standing right outside the window of his office Angela and Pam were having a whole conversation and Angela's holding Philip but she's not really paying attention to what Philip is looking at or doing. She's just chatting away with Pam. Are Pam and Angela friends? I don't know.
I mean, I do think children bring them together in a way. In a way. I'll say that. Well, while Angela's holding Philip and chatting away, Philip is only got eyes for one thing. The Galactica. He points at it, he's smiling. Dwight clocks all of this. He can't even focus on what Esther's saying. Yeah, and you know, this picnic in his office, this was gonna be a marriage proposal.
Yeah, he puts the ring back in his pocket. He does. Dwight has a talking head where he says the way Philip looks at the Galactica is the same way he looks at it. Hmm. And they even eat the same kind of paper. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Well we had to ask Dave Rogers about the scene because a while back he shared with us his love of Battlestar Galactica and how it influenced the character of Dwight. Here's what he told us. For this episode, it was scripted that Dwight paints
and hangs a model of the Battlestar Galactica in his office. And just to go back in history for a second, when Dave met Greg Daniels after watching the pilot, he pitched that Dwight should like Battlestar Galactica and have a Viper, one of the individual fighterships on his desk. Yes, Dave talked about this in his interview with us, that originally Dwight was going to love Star Trek,
which he does love Star Trek, but Dave pitched that it would be cooler if he liked this kind of niche sci-fi thing. And that is why Dwight came to love Battlestar Galactica. Yes, Dave said Greg even bought him a model of the original Galactica Cylon base ship for one of his birthdays. And when they were prepping this episode, Phil Shea asked if Dwight would have an original
series Galactica or the new series Galactica. He loves both series, but he wanted the original Galactica. And when the show wrapped filming, Phil Shea said that he could keep it and gave it to him. And Rain signed it and wrote, Dave Galactica loves you and he has it to this day displayed in his office. And we saw it when we did our interview with him. We could see it hanging in the background. Well I was wondering if we had to get special permission to use the ship but Steve Burgess said, legal said use it
just use it. Oh. He said that we were not using it in any way that it was not intended. Like it was a model that you paint and hang and that's what we did with it. So it was okay. And also we weren't saying anything bad about it. And also it's a universal show. Okay.
Well, Dwight shows Esther out the door. He gets a bean bag that says now on it and throws it at the back of Jim. The summoning bag. Yes, it's a summoning bag. And he tells Jim he's going to need him to perform a test on a baby. Jim says, I've got a busy day, writes something on his clipboard, tears it off. More clipboard acting. And says, you know what?
He's going to pass this off to his number two unless he can't handle it. And Dwight assures him he can. Dun, dun, dun. To be continued. Yes. Well, there you have it, folks. That is AARM.
Part one. Next week is AARM part two. Big thank you to Dave Rogers. To Steve Burgess, Jessica St. Clair. Don't forget to check out Jessica's audiobook, The Art of Small Talk, available on Audible. And I want to remind everybody that Kendra Adachi's book, The Plan, is out now.
We talked about it last week. That's right. And you guys, we hope you have a great day. We can't wait to see you next week. We have some really fun stuff coming up. See you then. See you then. See you then.
See you then. See you then. See you then. See you then. See you then. See you then. See you then. See you then.
See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis.
Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.